so right so thanks everyone for this
most interesting few days I enjoyed the
great deal so no I don't think my mind
has been changed but a few important
things I think were reinforced and
clarified to some extent so right I've I
found yesterday afternoon's discussion
the paint although I realized it must
have been for non philosophers I did
find it quite helpful in getting clearer
as to what's at stake in some missions
I've thought for a very long time that
the real challenge - the only challenge
to naturalism I take truly think should
be taken truly seriously is a kind of
illuminant of his challenge roughly the
kinds of Alex defense that is you know
our James in my book is subtitled
metaphysics naturalized or naturalizing
metaphysics I forget which metaphysics
naturalized right well of course the
alternative is - is the only alternative
we really take seriously - naturalizing
metaphysics is abolishing metaphysics
right it's self-evident to me that non
naturalized metaphysics is nonsense so
and I think if we were persuaded by Alex
that is the road to about that's
abolition of metaphysics now I also have
always thought as well and this was
reinforced yesterday that that issue
ultimately comes down to the question of
whether we can successfully ground
notions of representation because once
you get representation we can get all
the rest of the stuff that's really an
issue can we grab notions of
representation seriously not just in a
metaphorical fashion but actually
technically grounded in information and
resistance to entropy so I happily came
out of yesterday's conversation thinking
right there's a kind of general
agreement that that is that's the
project that has to be carried out and
ultimately I think that's what
determines whether we should have
whether we shall have naturalized
metaphysics or no matter fit I'm going
to join the general consensus that we've
heard around the table and I'm all I was
also persuaded that yeah free will just
looks like it's got to as a phrase looks
like it has too many barnacles on it and
this of course happens sometimes too to
phrase I mean rationality is not there's
another one like that in my in the first
chapter of the book I'm currently
finishing up on economics I say on
philosophy of economics I say you know
rationality rationality has typically if
InterVarsity never meant anything
rationality has meant what God would
think right since there's no God I'm not
going to talk about rationality again in
this book I mean I think it used it once
was a really good word but it's been
ruined right so so it's time to retire
it I'm inclined to think that about free
will and I don't you know again my
sympathies on the substantive issues are
entirely with Dan's
view I'm a compatibilist in that sense
but I think we should we should we will
we will probably never succeed in in
persuading people to understand that
compatible this position if we insist on
using the phrase pretty well so ok let's
retire it I I would have enjoyed a
little more description in terms of
things we could that I would have liked
to have seen us talk a little bit more
about I would have enjoyed more
discussion about interpretations of
quantum mechanics and it would have been
nice if that was actually a topic it
came up parenthetically now and again
but we really didn't didn't have a go at
it
James and I have written I've recently
written a paper which is coming out in
the book we're editing from Oxford you
pee in a cup next month in which we
defend the original Copenhagen
interpretation not the later Copenhagen
interpretation right not the coconut so
right the Copenhagen interpretation tell
me the Copenhagen interpretation that
according to philosophers isn't an
interpretation right in that one okay
original original
original board so we could have had an
interesting well go about that yeah well
that was okay all right I'll stop there
thanks thanks everybody for so many
interesting remarks
you